Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. This will be my black panther
wakanda forever video
all about killmonger
there's a whole bunch of stuff we have to talk
about a whole bunch of Easter eggs and obviously
stuff that's happening in the future if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos careful for spoilers for
the movie if you haven't seen it yet we have
to talk about a lot of the plot to explain the
killmonger character and what Marvel's plans
are for him going forward because obviously
this is just the tip of the vibranium spear
they have a lot of plans for Michael B Jordan
he's been one of the best villains that they've
ever done so of course they have lots of plans
for his character in the future of the MCU but
during the movie Marvel brought killmonger
back confirming a lot of our theories there
were a couple twist a couple surprises but I
think we all expected him to eventually come
back in some way we're ending Marvel phase 4 it's
the Multiverse phase this is the Multiverse Saga
just in general including Marvel Phase 5 Marvel
phase six it turns on the Multiverse Trope so
there are really like two major ways that they
could bring him back and explain it within the
context of the story but this isn't meant to
be a Multiverse movie like it's meant to be
relatively self-contained to planet Earth this one
Marvel 616 Earth so they opted to keep his return
within the scope of the Black Panther mythology
and he is a big part of the plot too like a lot
of the things that happened during the movie turn
based on things that he did during the first movie
this is all of it yes so when it comes time
for another king we will be ready another king
yeah go ahead and burn all that which they
actually address when he shows up on screen
at the beginning of the movie shuri is trying to
save t'challa's Life by recreating the original
heart-shaped herb that grew in wakanda because
killmonger burned all the previous crop after
he took the throne in order to prevent exactly
what wound up happening at the end of that movie
somebody else taking more heart-shaped herb
and being able to challenge him they don't
really get into this during the first movie
but sure he claims that taking a double tap
of the heart-shaped herb would be enough
to save him we've never seen somebody in
the Marvel movies do that before t'challa
took the heart-shaped herb but then took
an anti-serum so that it would leave his body
for the challenges that he fought against both
umbaku and killmonger and they just took it back
again to bring him back to normal power levels
the way shuri talks about it both her original
strain that they had in wakanda the killmonger
burned and the alternate strain that name Wars
people have the underwater strain have a lot of
Hardcore regenerative qualities so taking more of
it is sort of like a super regenerative drug in
the comics it's meant to be so powerful that
if you take it and your body can't handle it
it'll wind up killing you like we have Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine coming back in the Logan
movie he actually takes a version of this that
basically super charges his abilities but it
will also kill him like that's the whole idea
he took so much of it that it would kill him
the heart-shaped herb is so powerful that if
you just started to chug gallons of it it would
probably kill you at least at the beginning
of the movie she doesn't have enough genetic
material from the original plant to recreate it
successfully but she does wind up using neymor's
strain of the underwater heart-shaped herb it's
a slightly different version but it's close
enough biologically that she's able to use that
genetic material to recreate a hybrid strain so
the version that she winds up creating isn't the
original version they had in the first movie or
for the past ten thousand years because bashenga
lived about 10 000 years ago when he first took it
it kind of makes you wonder if the powers that
she's going to get from this are going to be a
little bit different they can play with that
in future movies like the whole idea is that
it's not meant to be the exact same formulation
that t'challa took so theoretically it would have
slightly different effects on her body or anyone
else who took it subsequently like eventually
t'challa's son is going to wind up taking it when
he takes the mantle black panther when he comes
of age but the idea too is that he was born of
someone who had the heart-shaped Herb in him so
in the way that Namor was the child of people
who had taken the heart-shaped herb is on also
possible that t'challa's son has some low-level
Powers just biologically he was born with I don't
expect them to call him a mutant specifically
because in the comics he is Azari the son of storm
and t'challa and that's how he's a mutant like he
gets her mutant Powers but as far as we know Nakia
doesn't have any Mutant Powers so when she takes
this new hybrid strain and enters the ancestral
plane she sees a version of the flooded throne
room because the ancestral plane as we learned
during Moon night and this is meant to be true of
all versions of the afterlife alternate Dimensions
where your Consciousness goes after death just
based on your belief system or contracts you've
formed with gods or other really high level
Celestial beings the place you go is you Crossing
between dimensions and it's a creation of your
own mind so she comes to this place because she
was thinking about her mother's death in Namor
and thinking that she'd find her mother which
is why she calls out to her first until she sees
the killmonger is here instead and just explain
which version of killmonger this is it's meant to
be the original killmonger from the first movie
like the exact same person that we saw but it's
just his Consciousness at the end of that movie
when he was dying he told t'challa he wanted
his body to be cremated and buried at Sea in
order for him to come back to life which you can
do we learn from Moon Knight you actually need a
physical body to do it which is how they brought
t'challa back at the end of the first movie like
that's the exact same twist they preserved his
body and brought him back from the ancestral
plane but the whole idea here is that he didn't
wind up in the ancestral plane because he took
the heart-shaped herb all wakandans who believe
in that place go there after they die like Suri's
mother is in the ancestral plane even though she
hadn't taken the heart-shaped herb because it
was part of her belief system and it's all part
of that idea from the Captain America Civil War
movie when t'challa is telling Black Widow oh
you know death for us is more of a jumping off
point it's not the end because very literally
it's all their original Consciousness is just
living there in that alternate Dimension the
reason why killmonger was the person that she
saw there is because subconsciously shuri wanted
revenge on Neymar so badly she wanted to basically
pull a killmonger so when she traveled there
she subconsciously called out to him without
realizing it and he he was probably pretty amused
when he heard her call like ah you're asking for
some Revenge I can help you with that and even
though they edit this first interaction between
the two of them to not fully reveal what they
talked about at the end of the movie they reveal
when she's fighting me more about to kill him
that he basically confronted her about this he
made her say it like I want to kill Namor I want
revenge and I want this giant War it was actually
umbaku and then later seeing her mother in
The ancestral plane calling out to her to
chill that stayed her hand in the final moment
sparing Neymar's life imbaku was like maybe we
don't start an internal war and burn the world
to the ground how about we not do that because
of namor's mutant Powers his elongated lifespan
his ability to fly like all the things that he
has through his mutant Powers his people think of
him as a God and if surely were to kill their God
it would turn into this holy war for them and
that's where they get to Eternal War where they
basically wind up burning the world to the ground
with collateral damage when she's talking to
killmonger that's also why the throne room lights
on fire it's meant to be a metaphor for the war
that she he wanted and what it would eventually
lead to but her connection with killmonger is also
why her Black Panther's suit looks kind of like
killmonger's suit it's meant to be kind of like
a combination of killmonger's golden Jaguar suit
in t'challa's last suit all the gold highlights
all over it's super flashy like killmongers also
super stabby looking like killmongers like you
might cut yourself just trying to pat shuri on the
back if it wasn't clear either her Panther claws
are also much larger than t'challa's claws like
the suit just in general is designed to be much
more aggressive like killmonger's suit so the
whole idea now going forward is that killmonger
is just available to come back in Future movies I
think the idea is that he could come back in Black
Panther 3 most likely the Black Panther movies
but also potentially other movies as well and
probably Avengers 6 Secret Wars we also just saw
a Multiverse version played by Michael B Jordan
during what if Secret Wars is a Multiverse movie
so if you're ever hoping to see a live action
version of killmonger who became Black Panther
in a movie that would be the time pretty much
anybody who's ever ever been in a Marvel movie
of any kind anywhere from any studio is probably
going to try and get into Secret Wars it sounds
like Kevin feige is trying to make that work
which is one of the big reasons why they're
doing Deadpool 3 with Hugh Jackman Wolverine
because the next step is doing a version of him
during Secret Wars along with Patrick Stewart
coming back as a version of Professor X there's
a lot of X-Men and mutant stuff going on in the
background obviously this movie invokes mutants
through the name or a character and I'm doing a
new Black Panther video for X-Men mutants and
how they're setting things up in the future of
the MCU because then everybody's disappointed that
storm wasn't in this movie because it'd be amazing
to see storm in a Black Panther movie because of
their relationship in the comics but because they
explained t'challa was married to Nakia and had
his son t'challa with her what they might do is
once they age up young t'challa is that he'll
be the Black Panther to have the relationship
with storm in the MCU so they can still eventually
pay off that black panther storm relationship in
the MCU just with a different version of t'challa
everyone let me know in the comments when do you
think killmonger will come back next maybe what
if season 2 technically because those episodes are
supposed to be releasing in like January next year
before the secret Invasion episodes most likely
Secret Wars after that I don't know if they'd be
able to release black panther 3 before Secret Wars
comes out so they might just wait till right after
Secret Wars to release that movie but there will
be many more Black Panther movies like there'll
be a black panther 4 because they have to do a
movie for Azari t'challa becoming the next Black
Panther taking the mantle and taking the Throne
of wakanda without directly copying the plot of
the first movie because that's basically what
happened during the first movie like The Lion
King but inside the MCU like give me The Lion
King movie but with Marvel characters now they're
kind of doing it again with t'challa's son baby
t'challa just can't wait to be king and avenge his
father someday I just posted my full post-credits
scene video about t'challa's son and what Marvel's
plans for the future of that character are click
here for that and click here for my full breakdown
Easter eggs hidden details from the entire movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next next one!